My name is Waqas Jawaid, and I trained
to be an architect at Princeton.
I majored in architecture and graduated
in 2010.
My name is Andy Chen, I graduated from
Princeton in 2009.
I studied sociology and
I got a certificate in East Asian studies.
Waqas and I met at Princeton. We've been
creative and professional partners,
I think, for a majority of the time
that we've known each other.
It's been nine years.
I was born in Karachi, Pakistan.
I guess I practiced art in all levels and
A-levels and I was really excited
to go to Princeton
because there seemed to be a
great number of opportunities there to
pursue the arts.
My greatest inspiration
was Professor Esther da Costa Meyer,
who is in the Art and Archaeology Department.
Her introductory course to modern
architecture and its theory
was one of the reasons
I decided to major in architecture.
I grew up in Los Angeles
to Taiwanese immigrants.
The arts were not a priority,
except for piano
which is, I think,
just what you did
because you're an obedient child.
Surprisingly, the most influential professor
I had at the Lewis Center was Tim Vasen
who taught theater.
He basically argued that you can't control
the art, it corresponds to the reality
around you, and taught me so much
about, you know, what it meant
to be an artist,
and to be directing other artists to do
creative work.
The Student Design Agency came about
because me and somebody from
the class of '07 who was a really
good friend, Tiffany Wang,
she thought there were so many
student organizations that needed design.
I had only started to do graphic design.
We ended up being extremely successful, very quickly.
Our studio Isometric was founded in 2013,
shortly after I graduated
from graduate school at RISD.
Isometric creates design that promotes
inclusion, equality, and progress.
We basically use instruments of mainstream
culture and adapt it
to think about the dignity
of marginalized people.
Morven actually approached us through the
Student Design Agency, and they wanted
to somehow comprehensively portray the
lives of Charles & Anne Morrow Lindbergh.
Morven was a great experience at
doing an exhibition, and this is
our first museum exhibition
that's going to last a whole year.
So they asked us for exhibition panels,
and we're like, "That's no fun at all!"
And we showed them, like, you
scale in this old mansion house, you know,
take the history of the house and reinvent
it for today. The reasoning was that
we want people to engage with it on a
visceral level. We want people to stand
in the aura of these people, and at the same
time strip that aura away
so that you could see their humanity.
All the design was catered to an
older audience but at the same time
making it accessible to younger people
as well, you know,
the height of the benches,
the size of the typography.
The curators were incredibly responsive
to our thinking. They loved
the idea of taking this old mansion house
and turning it into basically
what is similar to a modern art gallery.
We work as equal partners.
Every single decision we have to discuss
and decide together. I'm all about lists
and organization and planning, and you
know, who does what, and
Andy is a lot more free and open
in the creativity.
We spend a lot of time walking outside
of here, walking away from the studio,
even if it's in the middle of the day, and
things, there's a little bit of friction,
we'll say, "Let's step outside," and we'll
go out and go talk.
So that's how we kind of make decisions
and come to an understanding
which ultimately has to be
on a professional and rational level,
but also on a personal level, like, you know,
I get you, I understand you. I hear you.
Let's do it in a way that works
for everybody.